[Musique]
dans cette salle d'opération de
l'hôpital du saint sacrement
le docteur richard bassin écrit une page
d'histoire de la médecine canadiennes
pour la première fois au pays
ils installent minutieusement une
lentille télescopique dernier cri au
centre d'un oeil malade mais au delà de
la première médicale une nouvelle vie
s'offrira bientôt à sa patiente quelques
jours avant l'opération
jacqueline riu nous présentait les
outils à sa disposition pour combattre
les effets de sa maladie
la dégénérescence maculaire depuis 40
ans s'est vue ne fait que diminuer
c'est comme ça quand je fixe quelque
chose disparaît alors ça fait comme un
grand trou
gris foncé ou noir et pour l'opération
l'équipe du chu de québec a reçu l'appui
de l'entreprise conceptrice qui a déjà
vendu quelques centaines de ces
lentilles sur les marchés américain et
européen le président de l'entreprise
explique que la technique d'installation
est semblable à l'opération effectuée
pour une cataracte
mais pour le docteur bazin l'exercice
représente tout de même un défi de
taille dans le plâtre cataractes mesure
2 points 2 mm
de langage chez la plupart des gens
qu'on opère avec cette opération dont va
faire une plaie de 10000 m c'est cinq
fois plus après un peu plus d'une heure
l'opération est un succès jacqueline riu
devra maintenant guérir et apprendre à
utiliser sa nouvelle lentille un
processus qui pourrait prendre des
semaines
mais qui ne l'effrayait pas avant
l'opération dans la fnath chez nous on a
des mangeoires pour les oiseaux
mais je vais voir avec mon oeil mon et
que je vais bâtir le bouillonnec
et je me dis sobre c'est ça va aller ici
maxime cornu radio canada québec